people who have an infinite variety of  choices are less happy than people who  only have one or two  the millennial generation that you're a  part of suffered in some sense because  they  they weren't deprived enough and had too  many choices the advantage to being  deprived is that it's obvious what to do  like if you're starving  then you eat there's no question but if  you have enough to eat  and you have enough shelter and you have  enough information  maybe not as much as you could have but  enough it starts to become difficult to  decide what to do  and then you have another problem which  is that you can't decide what to do